after the post-apocalyptic hellscape
that was the r-tx 20/80 launch and
videos following it up with lessons
learned for the r-tx 2070 launched by
and large technical media took issue
with the 2080s price hike without proper
introduction to its namesake feature
that be r-tx which is still unused on
the 2070
this time however the RT x 2070 launches
at a much more tenable price of 500 to
$600 putting it at rough price parity
with the GT X 1080 Hana on stock before
that this video is brought to you by
Thermaltake and the view 71 enclosure
the view 71 is a full tower case that's
capable of fitting three video cards and
most configurations it's also one of the
better cooling cases in our recent case
testing bench lineup the view 71 has
hinged a tempered glass doors on either
side that make it easy to open and show
off and it comes with at least one rain
fan though you can get the RGB version
if you prefer learn more at the link in
the description below the RT x 2070
still has the same problem that's it's
it's basically a dead horse on the
ground that's been beaten for about a
month now and that is the fact that our
TX isn't really a thing you can use yet
so we can't really test that feature
there are things that use it but they're
still all tech demos so waiting on
shadow of the Tomb Raider to kind of get
moving in that direction a set of course
of metro Exodus things like that so
today we're still focusing on what makes
sense rasterization performance focusing
heavily on thermals focusing on noise
things to that extent and there are a
couple things here that are also worth
going over which is this is a good study
of how resolution impacts performance so
in this specific use case the 2070 we're
looking at a scenario where memory
bandwidth becomes a potential limitation
as you approach those higher resolutions
so the 2070 you'll see in the charts
will deviate from the 1080 as the
resolution decreases as you get towards
1080 in some games not on all of them
you'll see that too but in some games
which become memory bandwidth bound
the point of deviation is about 1080p
where the 27 he starts really pulling
ahead of the 1080 otherwise that rough
parity and performance as you'll see
through the charts and there also a
rough price parity so this card is the
EVGA 2070 that's it's just EVGA 2070
there's there's actually not a name on
it anywhere but it's the EVGA 2070
technically black edition I think is
what they're calling it and it's a $500
model which is why they couldn't afford
the extra ink to put black on it
somewhere it's just EVGA r-tx 2070 so
it's a very cheap model it's about the
cheapest they can make and this this
then puts it pretty close to the GTX
1080s that are left over not too far
from the 1070 TI so we're gonna be
focusing on those today it also means
that AMD is now back on the table for
consideration something that hasn't been
true for quite some time because NVIDIA
has been dominating that ultra-high
underwear and he just has nothing and so
it's interesting because because of
Nvidia's dominance of that high-end it's
all anyone's been talking about cuz
there's no reason to compare it to stuff
that is four hundred dollars cheaper
typically and it almost takes retraining
yourself to remember that you have to
look at AMD and their Vegas 64 and 56
cards because they're actually priced
pretty close to this these days so that
is another thing we want you to pay
attention to in the charts today quick
notes here on architecture it's all the
same as the other touring stuff but the
block diagram for the t 106 400 GPU is
on the screen now that's the 27 t it's
the same structure as the T 102 that we
discussed except it's hacked in half for
a total of three G pcs the rest of the
containerization remains the same and
we'd recommend watching our touring the
architecture discussion for more of that
in short there's still one overarching
command processor at top that deals with
shoving things into the GPU memory from
the PCIe bus and tasking the workload
there are then three gbc's under it each
of which contains 60 pcs of which
contains two SMS and then there are 64
FP use within those streaming multi
processors the end total is 2300 for FP
32 FPU is
CUDA cores if you prefer to use on
videos language here but they're
floating-point units they were being
honest so it's it's an interesting
comparison to the once high-end Pascal
cards so let's get into it we're gonna
go through the review we've got gaming
notes thermals noise and overall value F
1 2018 is an ego engine game by
Codemasters offering a stand-in
benchmark for comparison against most
other Codemasters titles or racing games
this game is highly GPU intensive even
at 1080p work towards that resolution as
we go at 4k we observed f1 2018 in place
in the EVGA r-tx 2070 at approximately
the same level of performance as a board
partner GT X 1080 FTW from last
generation also from EVGA we're at
around 60 FPS on each with the
difference within margin of error we
managed to overclock our our TX 2070
fairly high something we'll discuss
momentarily to outperform the
overclocked GTX 1080 by about 5.6
percent this is pretty close to Silicon
Lottery territory granted and we
previously found that the overclocked
1070 is mostly equate overclocked n 80s
if you're curious about where those
would land in comparison generationally
the our TX 2070 operates approximately
28% faster than the GTX 970 SC from the
last generation
it's about 94% faster than one of the
world's best-selling video cards the GTX
970 from a few years ago and note that
the scaling here should diminish with
the resolution and these vegam 56
operates at 49 FPS average permitting
the 2070 about a 20% lead and 64 is a
bit more comparable as we'll see
throughout the rest of these results at
1440p the our TX 2070 scale is
approximately 4% over the GTX 1080 that
we tested operating at an average frame
rate of about 102 FPS the GTX 780 Ti
maintains a 91 FPS average and the GTX
970 SC maintains a 78 FPS average the
our TX 2070 holds about a 30% lead over
the gtx 1070 SC at this resolution
Vega 56 maintains an 81 FPS average
placing it between the 1070 TI on the
1070 for anyone to on a GTX 970 you're
looking at an approximate 2x increase in
performance in this test the RT X 2080
offers a gain of about 30% over the 2070
price hike of $300 so significantly more
percentage-wise than what you're gaining
for performance finally for 1080p the
r-tx 2070 manage is a 136 FPS average
which still isn't CPU bound at least on
these cards overclocking pushes us
another 12 FPS higher for a market gain
of 9% here's where it actually gets
interesting the RTS 2070 now posts a
gain of about 8% over the GTX 1080
whereas 4k had the met near equivalence
we believe this is because 4k pushes the
memory bandwidth requirement harder
where the 27t had relatively marginal
gains over the GTX 1080 just to
visualize it here's a chart showing
performance deltas between the 2070 and
1080 as resolution scales notice that
the performance Delta starts to grow up
1440p then widens at 1080p at 4k the
2070 becomes choked by its memory
bandwidth and meets the gtx 1088 for is
another good test scenario this game
runs on the asura engine and is among
the best built games from a performance
standpoint we use this game sometimes
partly synthetically as it's DirectX 12
and asynchronous compute integrations
are the primary points of interest we
restrict testing to 4k on this one at
least until the lower end the cards come
out this is because it already post such
strong performance and all we really
care about is the scaling differences at
4k the r-tx 2070 manages a 64 FPS
average and Sniper Elite for marking
parity with a GTX 980 66 FPS average
this is technically outside of our
margin of error but is overall
insignificant to the player and is
insignificant when considering silicon
quality differences anyway for scaling
we see the gtx 1070 at 48 FPS average
and that allows the RT x 2070 a gain of
about 32% the GTX 970 operates 834 FPS
average again nearing a 2x gain in the
2070 this chart shows the frame times
between taurine Pascal and Maxwell
generations this is the best way to look
at performance although frame rate is
flawed in significant ways it remains
standardized and easiest to read but
we've been pushing for more frame time
plots as performance measures instead
just because they are ultimately the
only real metric that matters with
regard to frame x or frame anything
lower is better
this chart and even more important than
being low is being consistent the left
axis depicts the on present frames of
frame interval in milliseconds the spike
here the present interval the worse the
experience and fluidity of frame
throughput for reference 16 milliseconds
would be about 60fps the GTX 970 is
significantly more prone to choppy frame
throughput and its frame times are
inconsistent overall this inconsistency
is more problematic than anything else
the gtx 1070 and our TX 2070 both
maintain consistent frame to frame
intervals and that is where you get a
more fluid experience regardless of the
frame rate because you can have a high
frame rate relatively when looking at an
average that smooths over some of those
spikes that we see although the 970 is
quite bad far cry 5 is next this one
uses the dunya engine and is a Ubisoft
title the game is another GPU intensive
option for testing thriving particularly
on things like particle effects and
geometric complexity and character
models at 4k the r-tx 2070 operates a 46
FPS average with a low is relatively
tightly timed and in the 30s the GM
coined 1% in 0.1 percent low values are
representative of similarly smooth frame
time performance to what you'd see in
the previous charge the GTX 1080 is
again at rough parity with the gtx 1070
at 36 FPS average in this title and at
4k the 2070 performs about 29% faster
than the gtx 1070 the GTX 970 is about
1/2 the 20 70s performance and the 20
80s 59 FPS average leads the 2070 by
about 26% at 1440p we see the 2070 again
at rough parity with the GTX 1080
including a rough price parity Vega 64
is also nearby operating an 81 FPS
average and again rough parity with the
2070 and the 1080 1080 P is less
valuable at the high end as we begin
hitting CPU bottlenecks with the ti
class cards the 2070 manages a 118 FPS
average about equal to the 117 FPS
average of the 1080
we are within silicon quality variance
between these two chips where within
test variance between the jibs so given
how an videos boost algorithm behaves
given how a silicon quality is given how
game tests behave it's fair to say these
are functionally equal here let's move
on to another chart
next up shadow of the Tomb Raider the
eventual r-tx title that is still
awaiting proper r-tx support and tuning
this is an AI dose and Square Enix game
that runs on a modified crystal engine
at 4k the r-tx 2070 manages a frame rate
of about 41 fps not bad really but not
good enough to hold these settings
dropping to lower settings would permit
playability at 4k and compared to the
GTX 10 70s 30fps though it's still a
significant performance increase and one
which allows parody with the GTX 1080
14:14 heat positions the 2017 more
playable spot when running these
settings holding an 80 FPS average when
overclocked but we did have to drop our
OC and it's about 73 fps when stock the
2070 is again at parity with the 1080
again posts rough 33% gains over the
1070 and again what's the difference
with the 1070 T I will leave 1080p for
the article link to the description
below if you'd like to see those results
Grand Theft Auto 5 remains one of the
most played games today and runs on the
rage engine by Rockstar Games the
benefit of this game is that it is a
fairly mature game at this point and so
future updates that impact performance
are extremely unlikely this is valuable
at 4k the 2070 operates at functional
equivalents to the 1080 and is within
error margins overclocking provides the
2070 a slight lead but not one which
exits silicon quality variants the RT X
2080 manages a 27% boost over the 2070
and the 2070 manages a 25% boost over
the 1070 the GTX 970 is again about half
the speed of the brand-new 2070 here's
another interesting spin in this game
going to 1440p allows the GTX 1080 to
take the lead contrary to what we saw in
f1 this is the opposite problem memory
bandwidth isn't the issue in this one as
the performance of scaling worse than
the 1080 as resolution scales down it's
more likely that this behavior is
resultant of better driver tuning and
Pascal for GTA or game tuning or
something else
1080p also shows scaling opposite of
expectations set by f1 as did 1440p and
we're presently uncertain as to the
exact reason why this game performs
differently from f1 and resolution
scaling but we're still looking into it
finally ashes of the benchmark runs on
the nitrous engine
and as more parts benchmarks than game
at this point to start ox credit it is
very well optimized as a DirectX 12
benchmark this one is almost entirely
synthetic if we're honest because no one
actually really plays it for the most
part it can become CPU bound pretty
quickly so we'll stick to 4k and crazy
with a GPU focused test at these
settings the RT X 2070 is comparable
again to the GTX 1080 but as outside of
error margins in its differences the
1080 maintains a 2.2 percent lead
meanwhile the RT X 2070 is about 6
percent faster than the similarly priced
Vega 64 card in this regard Andy is
starting to reenter the conversation as
an option either we're no longer only
talking about the ultra high-end where
Nvidia is left alone we never
particularly liked the 64 and instead
favored 56 as a great deal over 64 but
the point remains the same Vega is a
reasonable competitor and is a bit
cheaper depending on when you check the
prices and therefore should be
considered in addition to the 1080
alternative to the 2070 those are three
cards you should be considering at this
price point overclocking follows the
same process is what we extensively
detailed in our RT X 2080 review but we
now enter the fray with more knowledge
of memory straps and Delta clocks this
is largely thanks to guidance from
professional overclocker kingpin who
provided oversight on GP memory
overclocking during our rip series
streams the EVGA r-tx 20 70 base model
operates a peak frequency of about 1800
megahertz when full stock averaging
roughly 17 30 megahertz in our times by
extreme workload note that this will
vary based upon workload as always we
immediately noticed that power is the
only perfect cap here increasing the
power target to a maximum of only a
hundred and fourteen percent and
changing nothing else we were able to
push the peak clock up another thirty
megahertz with the average frequency
increasing by about 50 megahertz from
there we manually tuned until finding
stability at about 2000 megahertz peak
with an offset of 980 megahertz on the
memory in our rift J testing we found
that 980 megahertz is one of the memory
straps or so we think anyway as is 930
and we also think 12 40 megahertz offset
is another strap keeping these
temperatures for the GPU I below 50 C
will allow clocks to average about 19 70
megahertz of these settings and on this
card but we found steady state
restricting us closer to fifty three to
sixty degrees Celsius depending on how
we controlled the fans more on thermals
next as previously and as indicated on
this chart core temperature heavily
impacts overclocking capabilities this
card is a relatively strong overclocker
but it's severely limited by his power
consumption it's possible that
higher-end cards with custom v bios
builds will have more meaningful
overclocking gains but with only a 114
percent offset maximum we really can't
get that much more out of this card this
next chart shows frequency overtime
plotted against thermals the value in
this chart is illustrating if or when
the GPU clock throttles to control for
thermal scenarios in this instance with
EVGA is cooler
we aren't observing temperature really
climbed past about 61 to 63 degrees
Celsius when left to Auto controls you
BGA's v-- BIOS modulates fan speed to
regulate for a rough 61 to 63 degree
temperature on the GPU typically
maintaining an RPM of about 1800 we'll
talk about this as it impacts noise
later the peak frequency starts at about
1845 megahertz in this fire strike
extreme test and then drops down to
arrange about 1772 1815 megahertz once
for north of about 53 degrees this is a
normal boost behavior for NVIDIA cards
this next chart is a bit of a unique GN
test that we do where we stick
thermocouples to the hottest MOSFET and
the hottest GDD are six memory module on
the board we use a power virus workload
for this test we're in the GPU remains
close to about 60 degrees Celsius once
again when following EVGA stock V BIOS
for thermal noise response the hot spot
NC P MOSFET measures at about 69 degrees
Celsius and the hottest memory module
measures 66 degrees Celsius these are
actually very good results thermally
memory modules typically want to stay
under 90 degrees at least for gddr5 and
MOSFETs can take up to and over 125
degrees Celsius in this instance EVGA
Schouler is more than adequate even for
a model which is clearly cheap in every
other department killing LEDs and frills
and investing all the spend into the
cooler was a good move here aside from
the obvious power constraints this MSRP
unit is
actually a decent thermal performer the
power constraints are the biggest
limitation here but if you're not
overclocking it's also not as big of a
concern and also to be fair power
constraint is why thermals are tripped a
complete non-issue for this one it's not
really drawing that much power anyway so
it's rarity for low-end models like this
$500 units to actually be these in
thermal performers as for noise results
the EVGA r-tx 2070 black tries to stay
around 60 degrees Celsius so it's
acoustic performance will hinge upon
your room and case ambient temperatures
for our testing in an ambient
environment of about 21 C this had us
typically around 1800 to 1900 rpm where
noise levels were about 40 DBA
the EVGA card is overall quieter than
the FE designs at each rpm level maxing
out at 50 6.8 DBA when I 100% speed or
3800 rpm we typically found that the
card sat around 40 DBA in a noise floor
of about 26 DB and as for the FE cards
we don't know yet if the 2070 Fe has a
different fan speed curve than the 28 es
typically they're very similar if not
the same but the thermal profile is
different enough between these chips
that they could be different so we'll
have to revisit that if we ever do get
an Fe 2070 and that's the RT x 2070 so
what we're looking at the trouble here
we're looking at roughly a 30 percent
performance increase for roughly a 30
percent price increase and while this
might sound like a fair trade on paper
it's one to one the reality is that we
already had this option it's called the
gtx 1080 so it's functionally a
rerelease of the gtx 1080 in so far as
the value proposition today buying this
thing
it's not any different than buying a
1080 it's the same price increase it's
the same performance increase over
something similar last generation so
that part isn't all that exciting the
only way you could really look at it and
make it exciting is if you say well but
instead of buying a 1080 from last gen
you're buying the newer car to 2070 for
roughly the same price for roughly the
same performance increase over
whatever other model you're looking at
because they I mean they're about the
same performance so it's gonna be the
same linear increase for roughly the
same price and performance jump you're
getting something that will get more
driver support going forward you're
getting something that has r-tx for free
included if it ever becomes a theme
that's use that's kind of how you have
to look at it to justify mentally the
card is significantly better positioned
than the r-tx 2080
that is absolutely certain the 2080 TI
is the top of the class you can't really
beat it period so hard to argue that 128
e is bad value 2070 is significantly
more competitive with even NVIDIA zone
lineup and at $500 you're looking at
primarily comparing versus the 1080 and
overclocked 1070 TI and maybe Vegas 64
or if you feel like it heavily modded
Vega 56 which becomes a Vega 64 with
enough effort and without any power
limitations which can be done for
historical perspective the GTX 1070
offered upwards of 50 to 60 percent
performance improvement over the GTX 970
generationally for a price jump that was
about 25% Japan when you're looking at
it so that it moved the bar from $330 on
the bottom line 970 s to 380 dollars on
the bottom 10 70s upwards of 450 most
cards fell around 410 something like
that so it was a much less significant
price increase generationally than this
one is and the performance improvement
was greater leaving us feeling like this
isn't quite as impressive
yeah and video set a high bar for
themselves and it seems like they're
having trouble meeting that bar from
last generation now this one we think is
much more tenable than the previous the
2080 launch the 2070 is easier to argue
it is not an exciting improvement but it
is an improvement and if you want it
comes with r-tx but that's probably
something more suited for developers
today because no games have it so don't
buy based on a promise do not buy based
on promises you don't know if they'll
come to fruition and we'll stay on top
of it as soon as this stuff gets
implemented in games we'll be talking
about it but overall the
is one of those things where it's not a
wishy-washy review it's just either you
want the 2070 at 500 bucks or you get a
1080 I guess and then if you like the
idea of AMD thank you 64 is kind of up
and down in price so when it's down it's
absolutely worth the consideration it's
just it's still somewhat variable but
stock for Vega should be a bit easier to
get going forward than stock for Pascal
so you have that to keep in mind as well
demand how long you're waiting to buy
your card 2070 though at 500 bucks is
reasonable if slightly off-putting if
let's let's bump that up reasonable if a
decent amount off-putting but over 500
bucks 550 600 is gonna be harder to
justify the purchase of this thing
because then you might as well buy like
1080i or something like that and one
more note here and video launch tactic
so this is something that you might hear
about today but there aren't too many of
these 2070 cards going out for review
actually they are pretty limited and
there are a few reasons for that so
Nvidia got the memo they heard that
everyone was upset about the pricing of
the 20 80 in the 20 80 TI and to address
that and Vidya has to our knowledge not
sampled any or if they have it's very
few of the founders Edition cars which
are a hundred dollars over the cost of
this one they're about six hundred bucks
so not many of those went out if any at
all it's the US media and instead Nvidia
asks the board partners to fulfill
sampling and NVIDIA required we got
confirmation from Nvidia on this that
the board partners send a $500 model and
if board partners want to send for
example a $550 or a $600 model they also
must send a $500 model and it's there's
not necessarily anything too wrong with
that depending on how you look at it but
from from the view Nvidia presented it's
basically they know that they have a
price a perception problem with price
and board partners typically do send
only their best cards out for review
which then really makes that look a lot
worse
in addition to the founders decision
price that was already kind of bad on
the 2080 so it's an attempt to make
pricing less of a concern I suppose for
the 2070 and that's why we end up with a
$500 card for the launch day reviews so
it's pretty rare that reviewers get the
lowest end parts without buying them we
have typically bought them ourselves and
some of the manufacturers don't even
want to send $500 cards because they
know they're garbage and a lot of cases
so very few and we'll give props to EVGA
for being one of them
vendors feel confident enough to send
out the cheapest model because at $500
you have to realise just how how little
room this leaves for EVGA or gigabyte or
msi to make a good cooler it's a really
slim low margin part here and the GPU
cost a lot of money PCB is referenced
that cost money and the cooler you're
left with like 20 bucks left to spend on
the cooler at the end of the day which
is not a lot of money for a cooler
something good like maybe Strix or the
high-end gigabyte or high-end EVGA
coolers there was typically cost about
$50 plus or minus 10 50 to 60 for the
really good ones and there's no room for
that here without going to $550 so
you're gonna see a lot of $500 cards
that have very bad coolers for this
generation but this is not one of them
as you'll see in our thermal notes today
so that's it for this one thanks for
watching subscribe for more as always go
to store that game is exits net to help
us that directly or patreon.com slash
gamers Nexus helps out there I'll see
you all next time
[Music]